stood I had a crack filling and they
took the filling out and the [ __ ]
smell came out of my mouth I was like
holy [ __ ] cuz there was an infection I
had a wound up getting a root canal it
put like you could hear it like pop
through and then just this [ __ ] [ __ ]
breath they take this breath my father's
found he was sleeping wife said you have
to go to the dentist
so why does your breath is so out of
control so apparently he had an abscess
a sac of bacteria in the back of his
mouth well when they took the filling
out and they popped by accident I never
have the balls to tell someone their
breasts want them to tell me your breath
stinks one cool thing about black people
they'll tell you if